Netta another emotional eviction when
did you make the decision to kind of go
around and tell everybody can I go home
tonight well it was a really great show
on where you think CBS and Big Brother
had me is very grateful for the
opportunity when I first got sequestered
and got into the house it was tough you
know I didn't think I'll be able to deal
with it and luckily I had to support it
the housemates and we were dependent on
each other but it was grinding people
see the competitions and the
communication it was very difficult at
the same time it was very fun every
single emotion I experienced in a house
you know we saw a lot of it what did it
mean to you that it was unanimous they
all said okay I'll send you home
well they could have kept me but what I
did was I put myself in position to win
because in the beginning everybody
thought I couldn't win that kind of play
so I started to make people turn on each
other I gave Ari that one victory so I
can get her to Allies immediately and
that brought me about two more with Ross
and I Marissa
so I started to put myself in position
to win whereas before I was just having
a good time and I didn't have no
Alliance you know because I figured if I
make an alliance too early that could
always backstab me you know so I was in
pretty good position but it was a
pressure cooker okay now both Shannon
and Keisha told me that they wanted you
to win you're gonna disappoint sorry I
love those well Shannon and Keisha I'm
so happy they decided it not to get rid
of me early because I was a little bit a
little distressed in the big house you
know the Big Brother house is not the
competition and then the games
everything's tough and they kept me so I
was actually going after those two who
do you think is out took it personal and
then I was going after James but you
know those are my sister and I loves
them so much and I'm glad they you know
was ruined for me there was only one
week left though less than a week
why couldn't you stick it out for one
more week
you know I could have stuck it out I had
my allies you know I was I made really
good relationships I know James and Mark
they had some things going on I was in
really good position but it was so hard
you know the Big Brother house is not
easy next year I want to see see it
again and see the new celebrities
hopefully I would do it again I'll be
prepared but I was not prepared for this
it was so hard and you know I'm after a
while I told us i'ma put you in position
when the same thing with the same thing
with them Ariadna and I think they in
really good position if they can cheat
and they can make it hold strong they
can get rid of mark and James and then
the next one probably will be Russ to go
but I want to see the one I would like
to see the women win okay like I would
like to see the woman win now you made
it out of the house with your buddies
here the owl came in handy came in handy
you don't understand this was like your
saving grace in that house it was it was
you know
we had only so many things in the house
to do and when you're home if the Big
Brother house missing your family I had
no one to hold and thinking about my
wife you know my family and when I
started to touch the olive oil and I
said what the hell were the first night
I was able to cuddle with it and remind
me of my ears so this guy all got me
through a lot of days and then you saw
me walking around with it the house cuz
you know the houses were the stressful
you know house because everybody's
trying to win and we'd get talking game
all day so it wasn't a joke I didn't
plan this you know pop TV thank you this
all came in handy where is this our
gonna go live um you know I think I'm
I'm not big on keeping a lot of things
but it was a great experience and I
think I'll bring home I think you get to
go home now what's the first thing you
do first thing I'm gonna do is call my
children on the way to see my children
and then I'm gonna call my way
[Music]